[Musica]
credo che mi abbiano invitato perché ho
scoperto un mondo extraterrestre
Anzi per la verità ne ho scoperti due
due pianeti extrasolari ma prima è
mediate di andarci in vacanza di venirci
in vacanza con me è meglio se vi spiego
come ho fatto a scoprirli e soprattutto
come sono fatti questi pianeti vi
parlerò solo del primo che sarà davvero
emozionante e poi sembra che nel secondo
non ci sia neanche il bidet quindi
sconsigliabile per noi italiani
andarci fino a 30 anni fa Sì parlavamo
30 anni fa di pianeti orbitanti intorno
a stelle diverse dal sole
era filosofia era speculazione perché
non c'era evidenza scientifica però
avevamo già la consapevolezza che
l'universo è popolato da miliardi di
galassie popolati a loro volta da
miliardi di stelle miliardi di miliardi
di stelle
è logico che c'è da pensare che da
qualche altra parte possa essere
accaduto quello che è successo a noi
dalle nostre parti nella stella che noi
chiamiamo sole
Parliamoci chiaro i pianeti extrasolari
non si vedono sono troppo lontani da noi
troppo vicini alla loro Stella non
emettono luce e quindi non riusciamo a
vederle nemmeno con i telescopi più
potenti del mondo
Però possiamo
scoprirli e studiarli con metodi
indiretti metodi indiretti che
consentono di registrare le
perturbazioni che il pianeta induce alla
propria Stella madre sono di due tipi le
perturbazioni più importanti quelli che
hanno permesso di scoprire la maggior
parte dei piani di testa solari
soprattutto di caratterizzarli cioè di
sapere come sono fatti
la perturbazione gravitazionale che
quanto il pianeta riesce a trascinare la
propria Stella per quella sua presenza
ed è il metodo usato nel 1995 da Maiorca
che hanno vinto un premio Nobel per la
fisica per questa scoperta
e quindi è un metodo cosiddetto
spettroscopio e poi il secondo metodo è
quello di registrare perturbazioni
luminose che il pianeta introduce alla
alla sua Stella madre
e quello delle perturbazioni luminose è
il metodo più usato dai telescopi
spaziali coro Spezia tes e sarà usato
anche nei telescopi del futuro ed è
anche il metodo che ho usato anch'io con
il telescopio dell'università di Siena
all'Università di Siena abbiamo un
telescopio da 30 cm di diametro è
piccolo è un telescopio abbastanza
piccolo ma la scoperta che abbiamo fatto
con il nostro telescopio è avvenuta
all'interno di una grande collaborazione
internazionale Infatti questo è il paper
che annuncia la scoperta è stato
pubblicato nel 2018
Sono 22 ricercatori di 17 istituti
sparsi in tutto il mondo che hanno
contribuito a realizzare questa scoperta
poi dopo la soddisfazione del della
pubblicazione dell'articolo c'è stata
una gioia immensa per me che sono
cresciuto a pane e Piero Angela mi ha
contattato una redazione di SuperQuark e
mi hanno chiesto di raccontare questa
scoperta come sto facendo oggi a voi in
un piccolo servizio presentato da Piero
Angela Su Superquark
Ma come abbiamo fatto a scoprire il
pianeta che si chiama kps 1B
abbiamo registrato il transito del
pianeta sulla sua Stella madre
cosa sia un transito lo sappiamo
abbastanza bene perché accade su due
pianeti del sistema solare quelli più
vicini al sole accade sul Mercurio
Scusate per Mercurio e accade per venere
la prima che vedete a sinistra
un'animazione la seconda invece
un'immagine fissa e quindi un transito è
quando un pianeta lo vediamo passare
davanti alla sua Stella madre ma questa
cosa la possiamo vedere così solo con il
sole che è vicinissimo e la nostra
Stella 8 minuti luce non anni luce
minuti luce 150 milioni di chilometri
quindi ingrandendo il sole possiamo
vedere il transito non sono eventi che
accadono spessissimo Anzi per la verità
se non siete Highlander il prossimo
transito di Venere sarà difficile che
possiate osservarlo perché avverrà nel
dicembre del 2117 però sappiamo che
queste cose succedono e quindi
l'intuizione è stata quella di cercare
di vedere in qualche modo questi eventi
anche su stelle lontane
come possiamo fare a vedere passare il
pianeta kps 1B davanti alla sua Stella
madre che nelle nostre immagini nelle
immagini del nostro telescopio ha solo
un piccolo punto luminoso dobbiamo
dobbiamo
usare una tecnica lo stratagemma la
fotometria la misura della luce di una
stella fatta per con tante immagini per
lungo tempo per vedere quando il pianeta
le passa davanti causando una
diminuzione di luce
Questa è la tecnica del transito quindi
noi non possiamo vedere la stella come
questa come questa animazione Questo è
il sole Ovviamente con due pianeti uno
più grande uno più piccolo ma la cosa
che dovreste notare con questa
animazione è che il calo di luminosità
introdotto dal passaggio del pianeta
sulla Stella madre è proporzionale alla
dimensione del pianeta Quindi questa
tecnica è davvero potentissima perché se
io conosco le dimensioni della Stella
posso stimare le dimensioni del pianeta
posso sapere se ho a che fare con un
gigante come Giove o con un pianeta
piccolo e roccioso magari più simile al
nostro quindi davvero una tecnica molto
potente perché ci restituisce il
rapporto di dimensioni tra pianeta e
Stella e se della stella non so nulla
bene C'è un'altra tecnica che ci viene
in soccorso La spettroscopia
l'aspettoscopia che è davvero
potentissima come come la fotometria
ci fornisce le indicazioni fisiche sulla
Stella madre quindi ci dice che tipo di
stella è con che Stella abbiamo a che
fare la sua temperatura la sua
dimensione la sua massa
e osservando continuamente Lo spettro di
una stella che sappiamo avere il pianeta
orbitante possiamo anche vedere per
effetto Doppler la stella che si
avvicina e si allontana dai nostri
telescopi che stanno facendo lo spettro
perché
in pratica così come conosciamo il
Racing per l'espansione dell'universo
anche le stelle che hanno un pianeta
intorno il pianeta trascina la stella in
avanti e indietro e provoca un blushift
Quando la stella in avvicinamento è un
redshift Quando la stella in
allontanamento Anche questa è una
tecnica potentissima perché questa
variazione lo spostamento delle righe
spettrali dipende dal rapporto di masse
tra il pianeta e la stella ma
quell'aspettoscopia abbiamo anche le
informazioni sulla Stella
a questo punto abbiamo messo insieme
lavorando tre anni tra il 2015 e il 2018
le informazioni raccolte da tutti i
telescopi che hanno fatto fotometria con
i telescopi molto più grandi del di
quello dell'università di Siena che ha
fatto che hanno fatto spettroscopia
abbiamo quindi potuto misurare un mondo
che non riuscivamo a vedere È stato
davvero una sorta di miracolo adesso
sappiamo
adesso sappiamo che il pianeta kps 1B è
poco più grande di Giove poco più
pesante di Giove orbita in un giorno e
17 ore quindi vicinissimo la sua Stella
madre ha una stella che è poco più
piccola e poco più leggera del sole la
temperatura superficiale stimata del
pianeta kps 1v perché è molto vicino
alla sua Stella solo a 4 milioni di
chilometri è di 1.500 Kelvin 1.200 gradi
possiamo immaginare che sia abitato un
pianeta che è una temperatura stimata di
1.500 Kelvin beh A meno che non non
immaginiamo forme di vita basate sul
molibdeno che è un metallo che fonde a
3000 Kelvin Immagino di no che non che
non possa essere abitato però la NASA
un anno fa annuncia una pietra miliare
cosmica 50
sono i pianeti extrasolari scoperti e
addirittura la scorsa settimana pochi
giorni fa
c'è un altro annuncio ancora più
eclatante i pianeti scoperti sono
arrivati a 5.300 e
c'è una left
un annuncio importante
due
di questi pianeti scoperti più
recentemente
sono
potenzialmente abitabili potenzialmente
abitabili finalmente
iniziamo a trovare il pianeta B che
stiamo cercando come facciamo a sapere
che un pianeta vi è potenzialmente
abitabile ve lo dimostro Anche perché mi
è venuto un attimo di
noi per vivere abbiamo bisogno di acqua
Io ne avevo tanto bisogno in questo
momento
e
il pianeta deve trovarti alla distanza
giusta dalla sua Stella per avere una
temperatura compatibile con la presenza
di acqua liquida almeno per la vita come
la intendiamo noi e è molto efficace
l'immagine che ha usato la NASA quando
nel 2017 ha annunciato insieme al Team
trappist un piccolo sistema di sette
pianeti orbitanti intorno alla
che è questo sistema qua e tre di quei
sette pianeti erano nella fascia verde
nella zona abitabile di una stella
Quindi con i metodi che vi ho detto
prima è possibile Calcolare la distanza
e sapere se un pianeta è in fascia
abitabile quindi il primo requisito
quindi è che sia in fascia abitabile
potete mandare avanti le slide Perché
non funziona più il
secondo requisito il secondo requisito
che è fondamentale ma ci sembra banale
perché ovviamente noi ci siamo evoluti
su un pianeta praticamente
ideale per come ci siamo evoluti Anzi
noi ci siamo adattati al Pianeta ma
diciamo che ci sembra tutto tutto un
regalo l'atmosfera
per essere considerato abitabile un
pianeta deve avere anche un'atmosfera
l'esempio e in questa immagine
la luna è la stessa distanza della terra
dal sole ma non ha un'atmosfera ed è
assolutamente
vi Sconsiglio di andarci in vacanza gli
astronauti ovviamente ci andranno Con le
dovute precauzioni
Come facciamo a scoprire le
atmosfere Come facciamo a sapere se ci
sono atmosfere abitabili negli altri
piani del sasolari ancora con
l'aspettoscopia qua Vedete un esempio io
posso fare lo spettro lo spettro vedo le
righe corrispondenti agli elementi
chimici dell'atmosfera della stella ma
quando c'è il pianeta davanti alcune
righe potrebbero essere enfatizzate
aumentate benissimo
se
sottraggo Lo spettro che vedete più in
basso dallo spettro che vedete in alto
che è stato fatto la stella quando non
ha il pianeta davanti se ci sono
differenze quelle righe sono introdotte
dalle sostanze chimiche presenti
nell'atmosfera del pianeta quindi
iniziamo ad avere un sacco di strumenti
per per
trovare il nostro pianeta B e per quanto
riguarda lo studio dell'atmosfera ci
sono due telescopi uno del presente e
uno che sarà il telescopio del futuro
una missione che sarà lanciata nel nel
2029 il James Webb ha già iniziato a
fare da corsa le atmosfere dei pianeti
extrasolari ed è davvero una tecnica
molto molto potente
abbiamo Quindi tutti gli strumenti per
per trovare i pianeti B il nostro
gemello ci accontenteremo ad un cugino
ma probabilmente no le condizioni devono
essere devono essere quelle
identiche il più possibile a quelli che
abbiamo sulla terra ultimo problema
perché abbiamo già gli strumenti per
trovarlo questo le distanze
questa Stella Si chiama Proxima Centauri
e la stella più vicina a noi dopo il
sole e a 4,26 anni luce da noi ed è
veramente dopo il sole la stella che
possiamo raggiungere più velocemente la
sonda spaziale più veloce più veloce
finora costruita dall'uomo si chiama
Parker Solar
che può raggiungere i 700 mila
chilometri orari per tornare a Siena ci
metto un millesimo di secondo
700 mila all'ora Bisognerebbe
consigliare consigliarlo ai meccanismi
qualche squadra automobilistica italiana
che recentemente singhiozza un po'
Ecco a quella velocità
Ah non vi ho detto una cosa importante
intorno a questa stella in fascia
abitabile c'è un pianeta extrasolare
scoperto da qualche anno ecco per andare
a vedere come Com'è il tempo da quelle
parti a 700 mila chilometri orari
impiegheremo
7000 anni Questa è la nostra tecnologia
attuale 7000 anni e anche la luce
impiega 4 anni per arrivare da Proxima
Centauri fino fino a noi
queste considerazioni mi fanno arrivare
a una conclusione abbastanza scontata
che tra l'altro è una conclusione che ho
sentito anche dagli speaker che mi hanno
preceduto guardate questa immagine del
1968 l'apollo 8
in orbita intorno alla luna vede il
sorgere della terra la NASA la pubblica
come the heart l'umanità rimane attonica
Vedendo questa immagine perché era la
prima volta che si scattava un selfie
con un braccio lunghissimo 380.000 km
rivolto verso il nostro pianeta e ci si
rende conto che la Terra è piccola
preziosa e fragile
basta cambiare prospettiva Per non
parlare se la cambiamo ancora di più e
se ci spostiamo a una distanza di 80
minuti luce l'orbita di Saturno altra
immagine pubblicata dalla NASA nel 2013
la intitolata the Dave Earth smile il
giorno in cui la terra sorrisi
bene
la terra vista dalla distanza di Saturno
è quella indicata dalla freccina alla
freccina ce l'hanno aggiunta credo
quelli della NASA
ed è quel pallino
azzurro
una manciata di pixel
questa foto Ricorda per chi la conosce
un'altra immagine Iconica degli anni 90
il pallido puntino azzurro sospeso sul
raggio di sole che di cui parlava Sagan
nel 1990 bene Noi siamo tutti voi
compresi almeno che non abbiate meno di
10 anni dentro a quel pallido continua
azzurro a quella manciata di pizze e
sinceramente dovremmo renderci più cura
di quella manciata di pizze e fra
l'altro io in questa foto sono venuto
anche abbastanza bene Vi ringrazio
[Applauso]